[Music]
the 2018 Billboard Music Awards were
electric churning out moments that made
us laugh cry dance and sing along host
Kelly Clarkson got the energy going with
a fun mashup of the year's biggest hits
[Music]
ariana grande recently split from
boyfriend Mac Miller but like the song
goes
she's got no tears left to cry
especially when she's on stage John
Legend also performed just days after
welcoming his son miles with wife
Chrissy Teigen the model hilariously
shaded him on Twitter writing Wow didn't
you just have a baby John smh go take
care of it disgusting the night had some
reflective moments too like this
performance from Shawn Mendes and Khalid
alongside the choir of Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School where 17 students
died during a February school shooting
the chainsmokers and Halsey delivered a
heartfelt tribute to the late DJ Avicii
his passing was a great loss for the
music world and for us it's a reminder
to all of us to be there and to support
and love all of our friends and family
members who may be struggling with
mental health issues but the night ended
on a seriously high note
R&B icon Sultan Peppa and invoke joint
forces to perform some of their most
classic singles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]